hello everyone this game is from the
same tournament as the game in my
previous video I was played in Sukhumi
in 1972 and Aleksandr borovsky has the
white pieces against Michael Tao and
like I said in my previous video tal won
this tournament and it was because of
belowski that tal had a soul so lead in
the end because molesky defeated the
mark time anova and in the end taimanov
got third place but this game is a real
challenge for for the young rising star
as he faces the magician from riga and
he has the white pieces so let's see
this game it's this is a quite an
interesting tournament so I might do
even more games from this tournament
belowski plays efore and c5 the Sicilian
from the magician
Knight to f3 d6 d4 seek after Sundy for
Knight captors and e4 and Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 and ECX displayed
the Scheveningen variation and we have
g4 at the Charis attack a 6g 5/9 to b7
Bishop to e3 and b5 by tau where f4
Bishop to b7 and already going for the
very sharp pawn to f5 and well probably
the best move is is definitely not the
one towel played but towel doesn't scare
easily and he goes for before he
immediately counter-attacks on the
queenside F captures on e6 and topless B
captures on c3 grabbing the night and
here why it has a few options he can
either grab this night and e7 over to
check or he can grab the pawn and go for
the attack and grabbing tonight and e7
doesn't really give him quite that much
so but as he plays the the correct move
he plays he captures on f7 would check
we have King captures on f7 and well
already this is a critical position
white is down a piece and well every
move counts and belowski plays Bishop to
c4 with check going for the direct
threat much better here was Bishop to h3
and only then castling
so in this position as a silent movie
will be would be much better than the
direct the direct Bishop to c4 that he
went for but okay Bishop to c4 King to
e8 by tau and velocity castles here nice
the east six it does seem like an
aggressive move and but it doesn't
really achieve anything after Queen to
c8 Todd would be attacking the bishop on
c4 this seek after some b2 is still a
threat so like what couldn't be
perfectly fine here even better
so after King g8 Belyaev ski castled
threatening ideas like Bishop to f7
check and toggles for Knights to e5 the
best move in the position attacking the
bishop on c4 also defending f7 now with
this knight on e5 and Valesky goes for a
wintry to defending the bishop we have
Knight B to C 6th all develops apiece
and rooked f5 by Belyaev ski defending
this g5 pawn because if style captures
this knight on d4 and Bishop captures
this pawn would be undefended tog goes
for Queen to e7 and we have Bishop to d5
and well here tau goes for a series of
exchanges that really really turns the
game around Intel's favor
he plays knife capture Sundy for Bishop
captures on d4 Bishop captures on d5 we
have each after Sun d5 tallies up a
piece so every exchange is definitely in
his favor and here a brilliant finisher
by tal he plays a knight to c6 offering
to exchange Queens the White Queen is
and if undefended on e2 so but as he
can't really capture the knight on c6
and but as he was for Queen to f2 his
idea is well I'm still attacking tiles
night here and well rook to e1 is
definitely a threat you know winning
between this Queen on e7
but tal simply plays knife captures on
d4 and this is the problem
the knight is attacking this night and
this rock on f5 and the problem is that
rook to e1 doesn't really achieve
anything for white rook to e1
tells him to place C captures on b2 and
if you capture the Queen rook captures
an e7 Bishop capture
97 well Dallas threatening upon to be
one queening so we need to e 1 for
example defending now rook to b8 and
well you don't really have a lot of
options here for white if rook to f1
then simply Knight to f3 check 14 the
king and queen and after the rook
captures you Queen Queen captures rook
captures and tallies up a whole rook and
the bishop and after this rook to b8 if
you don't play rook to f1 if you try to
block this pawn with your queen for
example Queen to be won
well tal simply grabs the rook and well
you do have a queen but your queen is
stuck stuck here on b1 and tile has two
rooks a bishop and tonight for the Queen
so this this doesn't really achieve
anything
so after night to d4 bit askew realizes
that rook to e1 was never really a
threat and he plays a queen capture Sun
d4 and now towel was probably tough kit
can probably capture this pawn and b2
this is the best move but he doesn't
need it he's up a piece and he goes for
the immediate Queen 287 exchange in
Queens and being up a piece this is
perfectly fine for tau this is winning
pelowski plays d captures on c3 Queen
captures on d4 with Czech seek after
sandy for and Bishop to e7 and well with
FAL being up a piece this is this is a
game over a couple of more moves were
played rook to f3 roped the c8 by tal
attacking the pawn rook the b1 Bishop to
g5 r up to b7 and roped a fade by tile
and after rook to g3 but I see actually
resigned the game without even waiting
for a response from tau because after a
move like Bishop to f6
you don't really have anything to play
forward white here this rook who would
come in to game with rook to f7 white
can't really afford to exchange any
pieces and belowski doesn't want to
continue this game anymore
so after rook to g3 Bellavia resigned
the game and well tal continued on his
undefeated streak but yeah
it was a great game and it was a good
try by Belyaev ski although it would be
a lot better if after Dallas King to f7
he didn't go for the immediate Bishop to
c4 check rather Bishop to h3 and it
would be interesting if this same
position was played but if tal had the
white pieces and Pulaski had the black
pieces
I'm sure tal would continue with Bishop
to h3 and who knows how this game would
end up so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
David creping for a contribution to my
channel thanks a lot I really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thank you all
for watching I will see you soon